you ready for this thing nobody's been
asking for my bus beats doing
okay so I just on this video on Twitter
that's trending and it's like this place
in India that has tea cream and then
foam that they pick up and they flip and
they mix it like that and it's insane
watch watch does he do that
[Applause]
Wow
I'm gonna learn how to do this today why
because it looks cool what's gonna do it
first thing you need blacks obviously so
let's go find wax
that's that's too small
you're no normal cups
[ __ ] sure you seize this one okay so I
got the cup now I'm just gonna practice
with some water
just to get like the motion down
okay so we ran outside because I don't
make a mess at BuzzFeed and I don't
wanna get in trouble so we're here
there's no people around it's safe first
try right here right now why did I blow
on and we got this baby
feel like a dolphin
let's get all over my face okay let's do
this
you have to like really extinguish
third time's the charm
[Laughter]
Don't Tell tasty got another glass I'm
honest not sure if this is gonna work
but we'll just try again
training montage baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
baseline the Camrys so impressed I
figured out the technique
you're drinking them
what I'm a magician baby
[Music]
okay so now for the real test I feel
ready I'd be ain't gonna do this I got
to put some tea inside this is it gonna
break it's a glass slightly hot stuff
okay you're only supposed to put in a
little bit of tea and then some heavy
cream and then some phone how do you
know that's the recipe because I saw it
[Music]
poteete now I just need some cream
no cream they're burning have to take
business elsewhere we'll find some cream
our feed we got our cream
you ready for this nobody's been asking
for my quest beats doing
I'm a jail it for baby
that is delicious Wow Indian tea right
here that's not Indian tea we didn't
follow the recipe at all this is an
Indian tea but the mission of the video
wasn't to make Indian tea is to figure
out how to make a tea and cream flip it
mix it serve it make a business I should
think
what's the answer of this video
[Music]
[Music]
do you know what's the span of character
come on you got four more Latino content
right here